[Music]
let's talk about a particularly
provocative set of experience that
Meredith to burrs has done just
fascinating Canadian research I've spent
so much time with so several years ago
when I first got interested in her work
and I kind of stumbled into her lab I
was working on a different unrelated
project at the time when I stumbled into
her lab I found her showing an array of
pornography so men with women women with
women men alone women alone and even
Barnabas having sex to self-identified
straight women gay women straight men
gay men and measuring both their
physical response that is vaginal or
response in terms of erection for men
and then their subjective response via
keypad how turned on do I say I am and
finding something fascinating which was
that wears male response was pretty
predictable the straight man actually
did mostly just get turned on to men
with women or women with women gay men
equally predictable the women were very
unpredictable and kind of anarchic in at
least their physical response so again
there was this big dichotomy the women
were saying I'm turned on by what I
quote should be turned on by straight
women by you know men with women or to a
certain degree I suppose men with men
and and gay women by images of women etc
but their bodies were seeing something
completely different and their bodies
were saying they were turned on by all
of it and perhaps most strikingly you
might think those bonobos having sex but
at least you know reach something
animalistic in men no the men showed
zero response subjectively or physically
but the women did show this physical
response to the
bonobos having sex so a lot of
interesting things about this probably
too many to name but one for sure is
that the idea of women's sexuality is
somehow more controlled needs to be put
aside if we're going to do any serious
searching about arrows and women and to
this idea that women are somehow less of
visual less immediate in their sexual
other men again need to put that aside
if we're going to do any serious looking
at truths about women's sexuality now
here's a bit of later
shivers research that both goes along
with but also pulls us in a slightly
different direction than that original
set of studies so remember part of the
original set of studies shows women
being quite anarchic in what they're
drawn to shivers decides okay let me
take a set of straight women
self-declared straight women and show
them just four types of photographs and
see what happens four types of
pornographic photographs so we've got a
flaccid and these are kind of
disembodied genital shots just so we
have nothing to distract us not a pretty
face not a handsome face it's Center so
we've got a dangling flaccid penis we've
got an erect penis we've got a kind of
coy soft porn female crotch shot legs
together and then we've got a leg spread
more hardcore shot so the straight women
do respond to all of it physically but
that erect penis sends the
plethysmograph the measure of physical
response soaring and it's just an
indication again of rawness immediacy
and just a kind of this is about sex
let's be careful before we complicate it
with all the factors that we habitually
complicate female sexuality with there
is a core to this and we shouldn't be so
quick to look away from it
[Music]